[Musique]
on est comme des lapins dans les seules
dans le dos des phares de voiture ou
excuser en cours devant cette épidémie
alors qu' on en compte derrière pendant
cette épidémie de virus à renforcer nos
lignes
il explose à certaines régions on a un
effet percolateur ou est l'effet cocotte
minute comme je l'avais dcri
c'est-à-dire que dès l'instant où on
dépasse 1 s'appelle tôt ça explose alors
monsieur darmana et puis c'est pas le
seul
vous avez machine via pas bon donc il
faut s'attendre à des décisions dures
dans les 24 48 heures c'est le message
que il faut s'attendre ici il faut
s'attendre à des décisions difficiles je
ne sais pas quels seront elles
exactement je ne suis pas d'accord
à propos du couvre feu qui a été décrété
cette semaine et dont j'interroge
d'utilité puisque de toute façon nous
allons maintenant à une mesure plus
sévère au plus gros films en si vous
voulez régional ou au confinement
globale mais les mesures qui sont des
demi-mesures iront en l'échec au
franchement on n'a pas le temps d'aller
chez pour les digues ne sont pas de
réanimation il faut envahir les hôtels
il faut envahir les hôtels c'est à dire
que comme il ya plus de place à
l'hôpital
ensuite vous créez des équipes médicales
paramédicales on soutenu par le monde
libé le monde de la ville je pense qu'il
faut reconfigurer clairement le pays
re reposer je suis désolé mais il faut
il faut laisser de côté l'économie c'est
inadmissible nous devrons les gens et
les gens vont s'énerver en tant que ça
mais l'économie c'est rattrapable
la seule solution à mes yeux c'est un
gros coup fumant total mais par
confinement total pour re confiné en
confinant total pour tester l'ensemble
de la population
le derrière 1re confinement il y aurait
évidemment des conséquences économiques
qui seraient majeurs et un recond
finement aujourd'hui qu'ils ont encore
une fois être un ultime recours
ça serait en tout cas la mise à mort de
l'économie française la mise à mort de
nos restaurateurs la mise à mort de nos
commerces en six mois
vous avez été incapables de nous
préparer à cette deuxième vague car
protégé les français
ce n'est pas seulement restreindre leur
liberté de travailler ou de se divertir
mais c'est apporter une réponse
sanitaire à la hauteur des enjeux
il ya besoin premièrement de mesures
cohérentes qui soit bien perçue par les
citoyens
il ya eu trop notamment depuis la
rentrée deux discours contradictoires
d'annonce flou je ne sais pas ce
qu'attend l'état pour dire aux
restaurateurs de france il ya un marché
où il ya un marché assuré
c'est les hôpitaux dans les hôpitaux
vous avez des professionnels de santé et
vous allez des soignants mais mon dieu
faites beaussier les restaurateurs pour
les hôpitaux de france je vous le dis
monsieur le député vous propose d'abord
sont irresponsables
oui il est irresponsable dans le moment
que nous vivons d'attiser les craintes
d' attiser les dites d' attiser les
inquiétudes
il n'y a aucun plan stratégique et on
vient là 24 heures d'un certain nombre
d'annoncés qui peuvent avoir des
conséquences très lourdes sur la vie
quotidienne de nos compatriotes sur la
vie économique de noeux des chefs
d'entreprise nous dire bon ben voilà il
ya toute une série de mesures comme si
on allait jouer aux dés ou à la courte
paille il responsable aussi parce qu'une
nouvelle fois vous êtes dans
l'incapacité la plus absolue de proposer
des mesures alternatives
vous n'avez aucun plan vous n'avez
aucune idée si vous étiez aux affaires
qu'est ce que ce serait vous ferez rien
revivre un confinement ça vous effraie à
moi je suis retombé au niveau je suis
retombé au niveau au fond du trou
parce que je n'ai plus de 2 de
perspectives et je suis devenu
alcoolique
1 j'ai la chance d'avoir encore mes
parents mais qui bien entendu sont très
âgés on ne m'interdira pas on ne
m'interdira pas d'aller embrasser à noël
on ne me l'interdire a pas je suis
capable de forcer un barrage pour ça oui
prenez ce sont mes parents
le nouveau je me retrouverais seul jeu
je n'ai plus de famille je suis une
personne totalement isolé donc c'est
très très très très difficile